simulation whoo here we go what's up
everyone welcome to simulation I'm your
host Don sake and very excited to be
talking about holding space we have
ohrid shapiro joining us on the show
thank you
I'm nervous we got you my brother don't
pump for this Thanks
so excited for those who don't know
auras background Aurich appear as a
personal growth coach leading one-on-one
supportive sessions and holding space
with clients for growth healing and
conscious evolution
he is also exploring sitting with bigger
groups of 5 to 15 people as well and you
can find the links in the bio below to
Ori holding space calm as well as his
Facebook page or let's start things off
with one of our favorite questions what
are your thoughts on the direction of
our world oh my gosh better and better
like
it feels like it feels kind of surreal
how that question has transformed for me
like my experience of it these days is
almost like the choices I make shift me
into the better timeline if you will so
tell us more about that
like my life just feels more and more
clean like more and more pristine you
know like I've exercised like
discernment you know in my relationships
and my alignment my purpose and all
these things and now like you know like
maybe I'll have like some bad
conversation with someone and then that
night I might have a bad dream and
that'll just remind me that those exist
so it feels like you can you can really
guard in your life like you can really
guard in your consciousness and that
feels internal and external somehow if
that makes sense
mm-hmm
so we can get to a state of our own
deepest alignment with our divine
purpose and the more that we get in that
direction the more that is reflected in
our day to day moment a moment and we
author our own positive or negative
worldview at every moment as well
yes and then choosing the positive has
made a big difference
seeing the good that's made a big
difference yeah and also facing the
negative just like meeting it meeting it
yeah how do you do that for me it was
grieving for me it was journaling and
grieving this takes us directly into the
journey let's do it okay yeah for me it
was journaling and grieving were we born
I was born in Mountain View good mile
view okay and you spent most of your
life growing up here in the Bay Area
that's right okay and who were you
growing up even the journaling and
grieving who were you growing up who was
it
yeah oh my gosh I was just like a nice
chubby kid and I had a lot of sides and
I could connect with a lot of people you
know like I could be athletic and play
some basketball and be cool and then
also like inside I was like a really
sensitive softie laughing in the best
way possible because I feel worried on
that feels good things like yeah like me
I felt similarly in some ways please
keep going yeah going about what about
what
so yeah you had this like ability to tap
into like basketball and hang with that
crowd and be soft and paying with other
crowd so you couldn't like Evan flow
between different groups mm-hmm yeah
yeah and it's so interesting I got I'm
just remembering this now but like you
know I could see like a grandma on the
street and just like be the nicest most
sensitive guy and it was so
authentic it was who I was and then like
in elementary school I could be like
with my friends like peeing on the slide
and like and like doing all these bad
things so so it's interesting yeah
damn that's so that is your your I think
you're unpacking for many people what
the dichotomy between that between there
to like most light youthful sides and
most dark youthful sides was because so
many young people did there was like
kind of like darker things like yeah but
also did the light things and to
juxtapose those I think is beautiful
yeah it makes me think of like you could
say our nature they're like our soul or
like our intention for incarnated maybe
and then also juxtaposed with the fields
the fields of consciousness the fields
of the people around us that just it's
in the air it's and to act that way so
that's why people will go to an ashram
or to a cave and realize something but I
think part of my path has been about
moving within the fields and like
levelling up the fields to be more
spiritually realized yeah okay so right
before we get there let's hit on what
was going on in your life around the
time that you started journaling and
grieving what triggered that yeah
well I guess you could say I had like a
spiritual awakening toward the end of
being a college basketball player at
Foothill College is that ddn's oh is
that that it's like a sister school of
the end and so I was a basketball player
there and then but I had I had this
spiritual awakening toward the end of
all of that and it was pretty cool and
then after basketball and then I kind of
I thought that was that I thought it was
a cool experience what was the
experience yeah well I mean so many
tangents right but but it's a good story
yeah okay trying to think of what's
relevant in the story
so I guess you could call it a heart
opening I was like picking up my friend
and teammate to go to school and I was
miserable and me and my friend were
riding the bench we weren't we weren't
getting playing time on this team and we
were kind of he was like the seed of my
spirituality he was like this good kid
from Brazil and so we had that but so I
picked him up and we're going to school
I was miserable and I was particularly
miserable and there was this thing in LA
it wasn't on my conscious mind but there
was this event in LA that he was friends
with the guy leading it and he was gonna
go and I thought it sounded so cool but
we had our last basketball game of the
season and so that's just not really an
option to miss and riding the bench but
we're riding the bench and so so I'm
picking my friend up and I'm miserable
like for whatever reason like I'm just
like man I am so not for going to school
right now and going to classes and
basketball and then I was like
particularly miserable you know it was
like pretty unbearable and that's
miserable to the point of being
dangerous or something no I wouldn't say
so okay but um so yeah so I'm getting
ready to pick him up and then as I'm
being miserable this thought crosses my
mind like this the thought of the event
in LA yeah and like the transmission of
Kyle sees who was leading it like on his
Facebook about the event like you're
stopped it was a Kyle cease of it Oh doh
yeah and so but your friend knew about
my friend knew Kyle sees oh cool
my friend got it inspired he was he
immigrated from Brazil and he knew Kyle
sees so yeah basically my friend got
inspired by colosseo and he made his own
like putting images and music behind him
riffing yeah and then it went viral it
became kala Cesar's most popular video
so
they became friends and Kyle sees was
like hey like you and a friend can come
to this four hundred dollar ticket event
for free oh you know like game over you
got a skirt yeah so my friends like
sending me his Facebook transmission
about the event he's like you're
unlimited we're here to play like bob
was like whoa like I haven't heard this
before but I kind of brushed it off cuz
I was just like you can't miss a college
basketball game in the last one to an
age is 21 you're 21 inch uh he was
probably like 20 and I was like 22 22
Tori okay yeah so I'm putting my friend
up a miserable and then among the misery
the thought crosses my mind about the
event you know I was like oh with that
event you know like and then I was like
but I can't go and as soon as I had that
thought then there was this shift where
I just realized that I could go yeah I
just realized that I could go and when
that happened I was decided I was gonna
go and then Jenice your life trajectory
with that moment yeah I love stuff like
that we live for stuff like that that's
beautiful
and at a moment and you the choice that
you made yeah that altered your
trajectory its massive and if we can if
other young people that are listening
right now have that decision that is
like should I go to the thing that I'm
just drudging or if there's that moment
that I could go and do something that
could potentially just change my life
trajectory forever explore that option
pick that option see what it does for
your life yeah yes yes and this felt
this felt orchestrated it felt like
there was a timing to it it's like I was
ready for it something but I had that
shift and then I became like completely
different state of being like I was just
like so light in the heaviness in you
you were light in the heaviness after
the cease event or be furrowing there
the moment when I was miserable the
moment I really
I could go to that event somehow then I
just transformed and and as I was
waiting for my friend I was just like in
I was just like a new man I was light I
was surrendered like in the best way
nice
I was like I don't know what I'm gonna
say to my coach yeah you know but there
was just this feeling like I remember
standing up on campus I was just like so
light like I was standing there and I
was just like letting myself like slouch
if you will you know everything's tense
and you're at school and you're on the
basketball but I was just like like
slouching and I was just like I was like
very open to like the environment and I
felt so light and I was like I don't
know what I'm gonna say to my coach but
I was like absolutely courageous and it
was like effortless just like wait a
minute like if you just like yells at me
I'm just like I care about the team you
know I care about my coach I care about
everything my my heart's open but like
I'm just gonna take it I'm just gonna
respond and it was just this shift it
was just this different way of being and
that's that whole day was pretty magical
you know there were like four or five
girls on campus that I was attracted to
that I thought were hot and I ran into
all of them like kind of magically and
so as almost like my heart was
communicating on the kids the whole
thing was crazy man
yeah so that was my you could say that
was my first spiritual awakening you
went to campus that day but did you
still go to the event in LA - yep you
did yeah a couple weeks later okay a
couple weeks later you guys went okay
okay so then so it was the moment
actually in the car where you went from
being miserable to knowing that you had
authorship of making a decision that you
could go that then opened you up to that
state of being that day at 4:00 for both
the coach your coach your peers the
girls all that stuff that opened up for
you and then later you went with your
friend a couple weeks later to the cease
event yeah then
what did you take from that that also
like the event was incredible you could
say I found that state again and then
after basketball as a whole which was a
few weeks following that then basically
over the course of the next couple of
years I opened up to this grief I didn't
even know I had that was like you could
say in my cells and it was like deep and
transformative and healing and I would
journal and I would grieve about stuff
that happened in that day that seemed
small but whatever my body I had this
ancient well of grief that would get
attributed to stuff that was happening
and so I would I would process this
grief and then over the course of the
next couple years you could I kind of
leveled up my system to be able to hold
that state of consciousness from that
awakening mm-hmm
called it an ancient well one yeah damn
I mean yeah people have asked me where
the grief is from I mean honestly who
knows maybe it's from our collective
maybe it's from you know my father
passed away when I was seven maybe it's
from that because I remember kind of
holding and not crying when everyone
else was doing that and then I also have
like my grandpa seven siblings were
killed but in the Holocaust and so
there's that ancestry there yeah there's
an energy there Oh obviously that you
just inherit somehow it's terrible grief
that you don't know where comes from I'm
trying to I'm trying to get this yes I
understand and now it's an energy just
as much as if it's an idea or an
abundance of joy you don't know why and
it's similar you know you're suffering
the grief of your grandfather who lost
seven siblings from the Holocaust it
still just carries on
it's interesting fascinating what are we
gonna do about it
science is now more and more pointing to
the 8 what ancient wisdom used to just
carry with them as an essence but now
science is like no there is literally
epigenetics that we carry on through
trans generations that are like yo my
grandfather siblings died in the
hospital dying the Holocaust I'm
carrying some of that I need to connect
to that spiritually and heal so that I
don't have these potential subconscious
moments that occur unconscious moments
that occur in my life yeah yeah
these karmic propensity karmic
propensity damn yeah I don't know if it
has any connection to what we're talking
about but I heard a story where there
was a native tribe of indigenous peoples
in the the Everglades that had committed
suicide in a specific area and later in
life hundreds of years later there was a
plane crash in which the equivalent
number of natives who committed suicide
were also in this plane class in this
specific area I don't know where that
song came from I you know I don't know
if it has any connection to the story
but it's you know they're suggesting
these souls that committed suicide also
happen to be souls that ended up on this
plane destined for you know Kat you know
catastrophe that's the
interconnectedness like that karmic
propensity to go ahead teach us more
about that
I don't know it's just a word that came
through okay okay so this ancient well
that you're green so you you have to
what what is the process for you of when
you find yourself journaling about
something that day or something that's
ancient in your families
trauma as well your journaling about
maybe one of those things are both of
those things every day for how many
minutes for how long no so most of the
journaling was about the president okay
and but this ancient grief would get
attributed to the President or
journaling about what was real for me
journaling about what
I cared about the most about that day
and just getting in touch with that and
opening and going deep would kind of
like would move the grief like and it
was it felt so healing yeah yeah if that
makes sense what would it yeah tell us
about what it would do with the feeling
of the of the grief because if you're
also journaling about things that when
you're in the present and there's
something that's really ecstatic you
journal about that as well
it's funny because less so for yeah less
so I mean it just felt so like like
meaty like to do this grieving it felt
so real it felt so it just felt like the
most powerful thing I could possibly do
the before and after was like being
impaired like being a drunk person and
then after I would feel like this ain't
like I would feel like hypersensitive
and like just like kind of like that
awakening I described so this grieving
process was just I knew how powerful it
was and it was interesting because I
developed health issues I developed
hypertension in a fatty liver and I
became like a hardcore hypochondriac for
like a year and I was bedridden because
I you could say I overdid this grieving
because I kind of became addicted to it
because it felt so sounds like there's
some sort of satisfaction in there you
know yeah so anyway but what it did do
is when I did journal about positive
stuff it felt like it was much more had
much more traction you know like some
spiritual people or personal growth
people talk about like positive thinking
or Law of Attraction and for me doing
this remember I talked about facing the
darkness earlier like actually facing
our like that stuff is the real like
that will take you somewhere yeah and
like post grieving if I like did some of
that positive thinking or like just like
envision stuff I'm excited about it just
felt like way more
it felt like more like I could believe
in it mmm okay so the recommendation
then is that tell me if this is right
that then when we encounter something
that may feel like it makes us uneasy in
some way that if we take a moment to
tune into ourselves and think and feel
where is that making me feel uneasy why
is it making me feel uneasy how does it
actually feel within me can I write
about it if I write about it what does
that do how do I feel after I write
about it yeah that kind of a process
exactly exactly man yeah I would my
journaling quickly kind of became like
very distilled like I became like better
and better at finding what was alive and
just getting in touch with like what I
actually cared about you know and so I
wasn't just like it wasn't like a very
mental journal it was like a very felt
journal and so sometimes over the course
of half an hour I might write four lines
but feel transformed mm-hmm but so yeah
that was what went down for me and then
what was your father passed when you're
seven you said yeah yeah what was the
issue with with your father he got like
this rare cancer when I was like seven
months old oh seven months and then died
when I went oh okay
Wow haha
yeah that I mean that makes significant
impact on our lives as well
yes oh yeah yeah for sure and and then
you grew up with mom then yes yeah
good mom okay and she was really
stressed about that whole being a single
mother and stuff and so I think we're
brothers - and sisters or I had two
older brothers two older brothers and so
I think I was three of you with one mom
yeah yeah yeah exactly yeah
does it reminds us of Ronnie yeah
so yet continue yeah I mean there's so
much to talk about you know I don't know
where to start
okay so when post journaling mm-hmm this
is when you're 22 ish yes okay okay then
what starts coming up for you at that
point you're like I'm so deeply
connecting the present and how I feel
most alive writing about it
what's going what's happening in your
life at that point where is your life
going after that
so
after about a year of being bedridden I
landed my dream job
as what's called a Z health trainer and
it's like this neuro health and
performance coach and you know I took
these like expensive certifications in
Arizona and Berkeley with some of some
of what I thought was the best stuff out
there on health and performance just
really cool stuff about like vision
training and like inner ear drills which
is like our balanced system and
proprioceptive drills which is like a
fancy word for joint mobility and
breathing training and just like this
holistic system with nutrition stuff and
so I became the Z health trainer and I
and I it was my dream job that is this
gym in Berkeley they where they had the
courses and then I interned there and
then I became a trainer there for two
years and then toward the end of that
and and that was perfect because it was
like this this environment for me to
grow you know you could say the grieving
was like this healing but coupled with
growth and then this gym was like
perfect because I could develop my body
with all these tools and then also I
could interact with clients where I
didn't even know but I was already
starting to hold space if you will and I
would go home and I would journal about
what happened with my co-workers and
with my clients and I would grieve and I
would like extract insight and wisdom
and so I was really using this time and
I was transforming all the time I was
showing up the next day a little bit
different and so after two years of that
I got the gut feeling to leave because
it started to feel contracting - mm-hmm
this whatever was emerging through me
this expansive accelerated healing and
growth process
so that feeling that was coming through
you that healing process that was coming
through the expansive process that was
coming through you where did that end up
taking you post the training that you
were doing yeah so I left and I left
this job I didn't have a back-up plan
but I was becoming more and more
spiritually awake
more in touch with myself more you know
beginning to kind of just flower my
consciousness my energy field I was
becoming adding depth to who I was and I
was showing up and I and I could sense
that I was bringing more I was bringing
more than just this kind of Zhi health
knowledge when I was with clients I had
all this love I felt so sensitive I just
wanted to be sensitive to them I wanted
to care for them beyond gym stuff you
know mm-hmm so and then you could say
that this life coaching because I was so
dedicated to my own healing and growth
it started out pouring can I have a
question yeah what would happen when
you'd start caring for people and they
would be like what the [ __ ] are you
doing caring for me I'm not here for you
to care for me I'm here to be like a
client of yours and the gym setting I
would just be sensitive to that I would
just shift and I was just like that by
caring for people I mean like becoming
people I mean like yeah being like
whatever is need ever is needed I love
you if you feel in like that I love that
like I love that yeah a lot of people
get spooked on you know altruism and
just genuine good people they don't
pricks you know and so it's throws
people off I'm sure yeah yeah this
that's well said that's actually quite
often it happens when people come to
California and they're like what is this
like care a thing about you
that you do and they come from the east
coast to the to the west coast and
they have loved you my heart is love in
people's hearts on the East Coast series
of course of course there is yeah I love
the California Jill yeah yeah so then so
then you would be with someone even
distancing themselves from the initial
care and then you would just be with
where they're at with that you say I
love that yeah yeah ok ok I have more to
ask you about that and later ok let's
resume us where we were at okay so so I
left and I left this job because I
sensed that I was bringing more than
just the Z health skill set and and I
didn't know what I was going to do but
but there was this out there was this
outpouring like in addition to at the
gym just in my life it felt like there
was because I was supporting myself with
so much dedication I began I like it's
the only thing I wanted to do with
people around me you know I I became
really sensitive to to everyone around
me as if they were part of my healing
and growth process and so so I was kind
of like this organic life coach I was
kind of like that already and then six
months into my leap well the cool thing
I'll just share is things showed up
things showed up to kind of support my
leap I'll tell you the two biggest ones
one was a living situation that was just
really nice and cheap and one was a life
coach who was like the real deal and he
gave me six months of coaching for free
Wow yeah if you know his name it I'll
say his name is Dan spinner and he was
just like this seventy year old like
master of life mmm-me some wouldn't have
on the show as well yeah he also happens
to be Mikey seagulls from consciousness
hacking his coach oh great and so so
with that Coach and the living
situation it's like I kind of felt like
I was free-falling after the sleep but
things were kind of just showing up at
the right time and then eventually I
made this post on Facebook I was like
hey I'm looking to offer like holding
space which just means like being
present with someone being present with
with what's what's there and supporting
them and so I made a post I was like I'm
looking to do this as a service and
there's a lot of energy behind it too
I was like I think I can do this really
well like if you're ready like I think
you'll transform and then what happened
was I had 30 sessions within a month
damn
yeah with Facebook Frank is 90 minutes
90 minutes yeah and yeah I'm sorry what
is it what what do you do I sit with
them and get questions like that
they're like so what is this and I
basically just wing it like it feels
like I had become support like I had
that hadn't become very authentic and so
I would just wing it and it would look
different whether we go into emotions
and I'm just like give them some like
solid love to some inner child that had
been suppressed like some emotional pain
or maybe what they need is like hey
you're a king like and just like empower
them and so mm-hmm
it could look different ways but most of
these sessions these 30 sessions felt
powerful they felt like they were
working and so eventually I started
getting paid and now I've been doing
that professionally for a year make that
money yes yeah okay so damn what a crazy
like trajectory to get to where you're
at today okay so and it actually deeply
explains a lot of yeah of who you've
become so thirty of them in a month you
got the good housing situation got the
good life coach and then just continue
doing it for a year holding space for
people and you would get everything from
digging into the and how would yes so
this you're not even doing the digging
you're holding the space and then and
then whatever's coming up for them
you're with that you're present with
that mm-hmm
so they may wander themselves into the
most deepest emotional traumas from
their youth or trans generationally or
they may wander themselves into needing
to be the queen or the king and you
support wherever they are at I we can't
do this live because my brother told me
not to talk about my mother and father
on social media so I can't you know I'd
love to do this and talk about this
relationship I had with my parents but
my brother said don't so I can't but
there is it does go back there is a you
know this I can't you know as much as I
you know I want to say oh I've gotten
over a lot of it I know which is still
it's still there it existed and it comes
out on you know my ability to UM you
know interactive on certain thing what
are your thoughts about someone like
that like it's trying to like suppress
like his brother's trying to like
suppress him from being able to talk
about his parents he's gonna be he's
gonna be pissed
let's yeah yeah talking about yeah and
it's not I'm not bad-mouthing my parents
I'd love them dearly I learned to love I
learned about love through loving my
parents and and that that's that I was
that I did it myself
yeah so as well I'm aware that it's it's
still it's hard it does affect people
and it is hard it takes years of shadow
work and self work and just so you know
I want to you know beat this I don't
want to have this age in my my god I
don't want this Hey
here so I want to fix it and be a better
person it feels really good to have you
sure I'm glad that we're holding space I
want to take full advantage of the show
and understand it you said earlier well
what what are we doing we're holding
space now and I'm like oh okay all right
let me get involved in the show and uh
hold space so great Ori this is
fantastic thanks Ryan
yeah and I apologized earlier we should
also see the story when I came in before
we had even met I asked Ori who do you
think would win in a scrap between you
and I it's a joke that I do often to
people throw some off and in this case
yeah Ori didn't quite know me and it
might have meant but I'm glad that we're
holding space now and I sincerely didn't
mean to challenge you or anybody that I
say that to and now it's all in good fun
you kick my ass I don't know if I have
that in me man yeah I understand that I
understand that I'm sorry
it was beautiful reflecting on you
connecting with you what you learned
love through your loving your mom and
dad and also just your parents and I
know what you're talking about
I took and also just you know John and
shut it off okay no I just it's not
necessary I was I was just I was just
saying like there are situations where
like families around other families as
well even mine yours other families that
it can it's important to be able to talk
about the things that we find most
important
to dig down and understand and like
sometimes it can feel like hard when
like someone within my families trying
to like you knows maybe stop me from
doing that and so this happens actually
quite frequently around the world and so
to get be able to open up bonor ability
to open up to what lies that are deepest
parts of our psyche is some of the most
things are the things that make us most
human yes well said well said brother I
love it that's why you hold space these
the the deepest parts of our psyche are
what makes us most human and so holds in
space gets people to wander into those
areas with you yes
yes
I really appreciate the stuff that comes
through you I'm feel like you are in
many ways some some that I feel so
deeply like lifts through you viscerally
because I also
feel like as a nerve ending of our
collective consciousness you are doing
work that I really resonate with so yeah
thanks man yeah so then walk us through
some of the you gave us some of the
examples right you're holding space like
what do people what do people do right
away when they're just like what what's
your like most common and your most
outlier man it's interesting because the
truth is sitting with someone one-on-one
feels
like I'm still doing it but I'm starting
to get that feeling I got at the gym
where I know there's something next at
least in addition and so like when you
asked me that question it's like not
even it's not what's been cooking
recently it's not been in the forefront
of my mind I still have that ability I
mean it actually feels like I in so
after a session supporting someone
there's a transformation and then
leaving that I feel transformed
you know after you heal your nervous
system and you open to yourself it feels
like your own healing work and so I
would just walk light post session and
that process hasn't stopped it almost
feels like each session gets integrated
into my energy field and then wherever I
go it's like that's it's like their
accolades like these energetic accolades
that that has happened
mm-hm well said yeah yeah and an
energetic accolade that you now have
embodied into your essence because
you've experienced that exactly and so
now it might look a lot different than
before like maybe now I really can just
like sit quietly and like people can
just like it can they can just very
naturally get there they can heal
themselves maybe and I'm just sitting
here like you could say that run began
to do that we do we do we can give us
ourselves you know therapy along the way
when we when we talk to people and just
that exchange healing oneself if we yeah
I don't
I got nothing
it's yeah we have to do it you have to
do whatever it takes and if you need to
if you feel you want to sit down with
somebody that you can genuinely trust
you know do whatever it takes
yes all it took me was about 36 years of
awareness in about 40,000 thousand
dollars worth of cocaine and I'm a
miracle of modern science oh my gosh
thanks for sharing yeah my pleasure
yeah say no to drugs kids
the other their other ways there sure
are I'm sure there are I'm sure there is
I like how real it just got I don't
really have anything to hide in that
sense you know I've been using drugs
since I was 12 years old when I started
with marijuana you know and that's about
where it usually comes knocking on the
doors of our children I have a 11 and 13
year old niece that I'm not concerned
with I'd like to stare them away from
that for as long as possible including
alcohol you know so you know I
understand there and there are other
ways but there's also you know don't go
telling a young girl who's just been you
know who lived a life being raped by her
horny brothers and don't tell her you
know don't try to you know
psychoanalyzing this you know you're not
going to therapy he's not gonna [ __ ]
work years of therapy talk you know
there's there's there's drugs out there
for that that's very painful don't you
know there's a reason why these drugs
are among us that also kill us yeah you
know there's when the heroin people
overdose that's what they ultimately
want
so
you know there's eight billion people on
the planet in there are so many ways to
die and there's some people that just
don't fear that and if they want to go
out they want to go out feeling good
it's a euphoric bliss and then it's over
so
I'm grateful for every I'm grateful I'm
a survivor but I have no regrets
going out of my drug use I'm glad that
I'm not a big heroin user found it
boring the whole opioid thing crystal
meth I don't want to stay up for a week
braum loves where he goes during sweep
and I do sleep is a wonderful thing
perhaps a brief exercise in death if we
really become self aware of who we are
on a daily basis Monday through Friday
you will see a pattern of personalities
if you will a nicely Gould glued
schizophrenia of sorts you know that's
just evenly out it's even and just uh
and ride those you know those people on
the brain of this machine you know that
shares Ron Vargas Ron Vargas is brain
let's go into Ron Vargas's brain who we
are who we can't be in our maximum
potential who else I can invite in you
know people's there's lots of that just
don't want to come in right now but I
could be a vehicle for beautiful
strong-willed grateful people so
grateful to be in the situation that I
have established in this body and I
don't I'm enjoying this who this is
today to be able to talk picturing what
I'm picturing my mom and my girlfriend
like piss that runs taking up my show no
no no this is what the show is all about
and this in and I want and you know from
watching the show or I'm just been I
don't I don't I've never talked as much
as I do and the programs as AI am now
but what your energy it's you blame you
don't don't say I'm gonna hog the show
there's an energy here that that allowed
me to do that and that's through you
that's you eat the skies are
professional
because you're here Ron went into the
deepest he's gone about his own self on
the on the show so that's how I think
it's a good good cheer good way to frame
it yeah look off comfortable and talking
about things as well a what we were
talking about earlier I won't bring it
up but you know I'm I stand firm on that
as well
it wasn't suppression and these aren't
sometimes the things that happen when
you hold space is that like yeah yeah
you aren't expecting it but there you go
you got a waterfall
what's your mob is this game at least we
should say I did yeah let's say hello
yeah Oh
big shout out to Joe thank you we can we
can say Morley in hacia we can say that
Morley inácio yeah Morley knows hello
hello hey thanks for watching I'll be
quiet now we can talk more about so
let's let's break down the the most
Commons and the outliers of what it gets
explored when you full space mmm
when you say that the thing that comes
to mind is like but wait like now I'm
interested in in working with groups and
events yeah
yeah that's what came through and have
fun with it no I'm seeing a fun
engagement you know this is kind of so
right yes yes but yeah but were you
curious about like examples of
one-on-one sessions and what they were
like that way yeah let's let's do that
and then we'll walk our way into the
larger size groups and events as well
yeah okay it really is like always
different
it does feel that way you know but it's
sitting with a person and being
sensitive to what wants to come through
actually sometimes sometimes it would
get on me like you know I've had some
really cool clients who have really
developed themselves kind of like some
people on your show and you guys and
sometimes the authentic flow of it is
where it's kind of like they start
supporting me and that just feels true
and it's kind of crazy to say but I'm
not yeah yeah you know like the thing
that comes to mind is this guy door who
lives at the co Hawk house the
consciousness aqui house in like half
hour sessions would be him supporting me
in a sense so it's like we talked about
energetic accolades right so he has
these accolades of like this really
smart like successful older guy in the
world
who's like done big business things in
like I think he went to the Israeli army
in like so there was something there for
me to integrate and that's usually the
case if with two human beings like we're
gonna pick up some accolades along the
way it's not about it's not like I'm
just like this absolute coach you know I
hope that kind of answers oh yeah it
similarly happens on the program is that
the person like shines that their best
teaching about what they're caring about
and inspiring other people but also we
get to learn so much we level up by
listening to them and
and yeah and forgive further on our
synthesis yes yeah so that bit does
really resonate so then get like give us
the most you know give us the most
common like thing that people go to also
what are some outliers mm-hmm yeah well
yeah so do you want more water by the
way yeah that'd be great Graham so thank
you thanks Mel
yeah okay yeah so give us common and
outliers all right so I would say thanks
Ron well thank you brother so I would
say the most common thing is like this
kind of meeting the darkness thing
because that's what I really like it
just feels healing and real and so that
can be grief like with me or like shame
and that might take like 40 minutes to
gain their the comfort and or maybe less
nowadays but so maybe the most common is
like some sort of emotional opening and
like processing and like loving you know
like us just holding that and caring and
that feels good I think that can really
there's nothing like emotions you know
in terms of feeling transformed and
really good but sometimes it can be just
playful you know like I've had you know
there's this one guy who was like you
know we were in his like business office
and I was like why are you scared to be
intense like just intuitively I knew
that was there's like a lion but like he
wasn't expressing it and so he got up
and he pushed me over the chair and I
fell to the ground and there was a space
there that that could happen you know we
were so you know whether the however the
being wants to expand whether they're
once some energies want to express you
know there was a woman whose brothers
whose brother was killed by the Cuban
government like decades ago and she has
this like rage like this absolute anger
and um what I got and and now she has
all these health issues and anxiety but
what I got her to do in a session was to
find those energies feel them with me
like get to it go there and then share
what the message of them is so for
example like and and you can get a
really clean like expression of the
message right because maybe like maybe
like on the surface because I journaled
so much I could good at like distilling
like the heart messages like the essence
the undistorted messages of emotions and
energies so maybe before doing that
distillation it might be like oh yeah
what I want to say that the Cuban
government is like [ __ ] you whatever but
but maybe after it's like you're not
helping and then like some really like
juicy like days that just like shares
them and then
so undistorted messages of emotion yeah
yeah yeah
do you write poetry what's that around
your write poetry do you you don't used
to eat the journal even what you're
talking about
try written poetry sporadically more of
a journal or I do like writing poetry
but I don't do it that much
what does it what's the difference
between the two the examples that you
just gave there sometimes it may be like
we go with this initial gut instinct of
doing something like raging is that an
undistorted message of emotion or if you
were to hold space with me and we were
to get to that point you know what is it
exactly where did that come from be
there with it and then come again it
would be less distorted what do you mean
I don't know if so like sometimes that
initial outburst that we have of emotion
if you would hold space with us and like
I'm curious what emotion you have right
now like what's the energy because I
feel something I feel something kind of
dense I feel that more than the words
are speaking because I'm so sensitive
and so
mmm feeling curious about it hmm
yeah
I don't know what the denseness is it's
definitely felt like
like reconnecting to all that is several
times throughout the show to kind of
yeah
to kind of put myself into the oneness
several times throughout the show
because that's how I feel when I'm
around you we got I'm able to tap into
that deeper more frequent
so I wonder what the denseness is - then
should I try to intuitively read you
sure yeah okay
it's very deep like it's like
maybe like a hurt
this is just something a story but like
I have this image of like a kid who
didn't get what he wants
I don't I barely know myself I'm trying
to learn about myself every single day
so this may have something to do with it
I don't know yeah yeah
sometimes we can say things like that
like something that's deep something
that hurts something that is like a kid
not getting what they want and it can be
like pretty applicable to like lot of
people right yeah yeah yeah yeah I
appreciate you go in there a little with
me it's it's a it's a fun thing I mean
like to be able to practice like you
said that in Tooting through I gazing is
that a major component of it that you
stay aitai locked with the person you're
holding space with yeah just to try to
like just to try to read like what their
eyes are saying there have been some
sessions where like the whole thing or
Matt or at least like the culmination is
like this reading of like all these
feelings and who knows like how spot-on
like you said like we don't even know
what we are like we just have these
energies and you could say their
collective energies but um but yeah this
it can be really healing to be seen in
these energies you know
yeah should we keep going sure exactly
I'm 55 well yeah you mean keep going
keep going in the unpacking of what we
were doing between us on like what we
thought was dense or where we were just
that with eye contact and what you do in
the sessions which one of those that
first the first one what was dense okay
interesting yeah
yeah I would like to as well I'm let's
see where it goes
okay so like so what if you allow
yourself to go back to that sense of
being heavy with me okay all right let's
do it all right
Wow it already doesn't feel as good I
don't know why got it
I like feeling like a lot hmm well dude
you're talking to the heaviness King
I've spent a lot of surrendering of the
heaviness if you want it let's surrender
to heaviness okay all right let's do it
okay you're raising yeah yeah man
yeah okay all right where do we go from
here okay so I'll just share what I'm
noticing which is that I really feel my
body in the chair right now like I was
not feeling my body in the chair that
much earlier I was feeling kind of more
like light and now I feel yeah okay all
right
so so what's it like to start to let
yourself feel heavy
it feels like I'm still clinging to the
like lightness like I'm still clinging
to feeling light
what would it be weird if you allowed
yourself to get all emotional on your
show no I'm super down for that yeah
yeah we've done it before
all right yeah yeah
just allowing the energy to take you you
know like okay
what do you do when you go into the
denseness when you go into that where'd
he go how do you do that
I just maintain my breathing and give up
everything else okay so
yeah almost like you let yourself drown
okay
like you're nothing but a breath and
you're just allowing um this emotion to
have its way with you
looking good keep keep it up
it's really healthy to grieve to grieve
like this
and
how does it feel to be seen by seen in
this
I feel like it's important so
there's not a lot of room in our culture
for this
yes socially yeah yeah correct
but right now there is yeah
the first things that come up when I go
to that density when I'm in that state
of breath and density it is like you
know who was who was I growing up you
know what inputs that I taken from my
family and my environment from the
genetics as well as from the environment
yes to become Who I am now
and then what do I not know about myself
regarding back all those stimuli that I
don't know about right
and if I learn about them that they can
help unleash me I might full this better
yeah do you feel this heaviness at all
being digested by us I feel like this
yeah yeah as we talk about it it is yeah
yeah so I live for that
so creating the space that makes it easy
for people to
be with you in the process of digesting
density
yeah
I yam and I feel like we're just tapping
in we were just tapping in you know but
thank you for going there because that's
can be hard to do for some people but I
know you've worked on yourself a lot so
and we can also revisit this another
time down the line where we just start
the episode by diving into density maybe
Ron um yeah yeah something like that
yeah that could be interesting
all right let's let's let's visit the we
did a bit on the one on one side what
about when it happens one too many and
also at events as well
yeah so this holding space it feels like
the coolest thing about it is that I'm
like a vessel for it more than anything
else not a coach not on I can be those
expressions as this more faceless vessel
that can become what's needed and
there's a sense of being with someone
one on one the vessel kept developing
like I would have all these like people
talk about Kundalini awakening I would
have these energetic openings and I
would have all this breath holding like
exercises that would just happen like
it's almost like my body knew its own
yoga that was like emerging through me
and like this quote-unquote vessel would
just transform to be a better and better
space holder and so then there was a
sense okay being one on one with someone
is beautiful but I can feel that there I
can hold more there's this capacity here
to hold more and so I had to cool
fifteen person sessions I did one at a
church in Palo Alto
and I did one at the consciousness
hacking house for my birthday and they
were both really awesome and
that was a fun exploration to hold maybe
some heaviness with a group and maybe
maybe lead some connection games and
things like that and so that's one thing
that's one thing that's also on the
frontier just like being with groups and
playing with that sometimes I sometimes
I have my dream is just just like just
to be there in just hold space without
even talking and like people don't even
have to look at me like they can just
like remember that party at the end of
awakened futures summit mm-hmm I
remember just sitting on the floor and
kind of meditating but when I meditate
it's not like okay boundary like let me
like a tune of this no it's like it's
like really just like opening to the
space and like holding it mmm
so so in terms of then what's next from
the one-on-one thing it's working with
groups and also just like holding events
if you will just like being with the
whole thing and just like interacting
with it as if it were a session which is
kind of funny to say but I love that
yeah it's a big organism yes and the
different components of the organism in
many ways are the humans that are in
attendance and the way that they're
interfacing with each other the
relationships between them yes so when
you are there like at awakened futures
like behind the front desk tables and
you're standing there all like I'm here
and like that's what you give off to
people is like I'm here and then they'll
see that and they have the potential to
engage with you and at that point then
for wherever they need wherever they're
at and it varies between the people that
come up to you that you can then engage
them and hold space for them at an event
right and help the trajectory of that
component of the organism
I love that yeah that's great
there's so much good with that like that
why don't we have that more at event
it's kind of like the space holders of
events I love that yeah so that's one of
the next Ori holding space.com
availability so he's gonna that's what's
been marinating yeah that good I like
that container which is which i think is
going to be showing up more in our
future it's gonna be more of a real
thing that's not under the radar I think
it would be less under the radar more
people will know about this yeah yeah
like a holding space should the holding
space area be very easily visible so I
will know exactly where it is that an
event or do you want it to be bacon
baked more less these are the questions
we need to be asking yeah I'm glad you
enjoyed that question so teachers
conspicuous or inconspicuous which one
is better for speaking of which I have a
question you should solicit your service
to law enforcement to interrogate
suspected criminals you can instead of
that this is awful
by the way the suggestion it's totally
devil's advocate you know but you know
you could interrogate the espeak by
holding space and they were just
willfully you know start from the bottom
where it all comes from and this and
then of course I ended up you know
stabbing her and they would commit and
confess to the crime
know is that I would just be interested
to like evolve I don't want to
interrogate anyone like I would just be
like yeah
I would just want to raise the vibe by
you do that's that's what I'm saying
there's a vibe there that you know it
allows me to surrender whereas maybe the
old method is this like hardcore
interrogation in that setting maybe
there's space for someone to come in
that is better at holding space to
engage with someone that may have
committed a crime and and to raise like
you said the consciousness in that
environment to where the person feels
like they actually want to work through
what happened yeah however when what
they've done is gonna send them to jail
for the rest of IV you're gonna be a
little apt to be a liar maybe not yeah
there doesn't necessarily have to
there's all kinds of factors you know
yeah totally things so then okay let's
talk about this on one side we have the
conspicuous placement of the holding
space people at an event right they're
very visible yeah on the other side we
have kind of like I don't know like what
would it look like if it was
inconspicuous like just some person kind
of hanging out and being present how
would it look like yet till it tell us
about this and which one do you think is
good should we how can we test these
that's a great question so I feel like
up until now I've been embodying
inconspicuous a lot mm-hmm
I've been going to all kinds of events
and exploring this I drove to LA to like
go to a documentary screening and like
support their cause but also explore
this and and I went to like a March for
the climate change and just different
things so up till now it's been
inconspicuous but I do think it's of a
value to have a place in the world when
you're doing this kind of work and for
people's conscious minds to know about
it some people that really inspire me
are these like spiritual heavyweights
like this guy Sadhguru who
you know him we love him so if you go
spiritual heavyweight
yeah like enlightened sages out like
Alma the hugging Saint you know do you
know about her what's her name again
um am ma am ma yeah I would call her a
heavyweight as well virtual heavyweights
interesting
and so so you better believe like if
you're in Alma or sadguru's like
quote-unquote field mm-hmm like that
there's something there like it means
something yeah
and so but they would be conspicuously
doing it yeah yeah they have a place in
the world like an official place they're
not doing they're not under the radar
about what they're doing totally when
you're in their field it's evident that
there is something happening between
them and the other people that are in
that field that is about raising the
consciousness yeah and why would we ever
carry ourselves in a way that isn't that
because everywhere I go now I'm trying
to carry the most light with me all the
time mm-hmm and it emerges out of all of
the actions today for an hour and a half
of working out laying out in the grass
and get like talking to people on the
run all the stuff that I was doing that
people were lit up in there and
engagements with me about everything in
life and it was just so fun how we can
do like why would we ever not do that we
are a direct mirror our worldview and
our mindset directly mirrors into
civilization so if we are agitated upset
pissed off we're going to encounter that
essence in the exterior world and if we
are happy light all that stuff we're
gonna encounter and spread that the
butterfly effect law of attraction so
many of these ways of putting it why
would we ever do the other one
the other one yeah it doesn't even make
it doesn't mix like we want to train
ourselves to like you said that grew um
that spiritual heavyweight but we also
want to not take on so much from other
people that we don't have our own that
it can off ground ourselves sometimes
with the spiritual heavyweights it's
really hard to like off ground them but
on ground them yeah yeah yeah
yeah
I'm glad that you that you've been even
traveling as well to events to explore
what it looks like to be doing this and
you said you were doing it you were
doing it inconspicuously yeah okay you
were doing it in like a more hidden way
just present but not announcing it
holding space sign yeah exactly yeah
when you were doing that at awakened
futures to their inconspicuously I would
say so yeah
and you'd say that some of the spiritual
heavyweights do it conspicuously yeah
and just in general like in our culture
in our society whoever is like leading
like my experience is anywhere you go
the space is being held it's like
there's a consciousness to that place
and usually culturally like it's like
the speaker or like the person running
the thing you know but my experience is
that that doesn't have to be the case
mm-hmm that it can be found around the
event as well not with the non speakers
yeah yeah so it's like maybe a person on
stage is leading a talk or something and
then in a sense they're holding space
because their consciousness everyone in
the room is kind of like absorbing it
like everyone's swimming in their space
to an extent yes and I think that like
you said I think this can be done
conspicuously and inconspicuously
probably yeah yeah
did we show them the image at least
throughout of amore holding space yes it
sorry
no it's all good we can I'm sorry did
you tell me there was an image there and
I totally forgot about it no it's all
good it's all good just find it show it
now well we can't just no yeah yeah it's
just that it's just in the Ori Shapira
folder it's will bring will bring will
bring it up no it's cool it's it's the
same thing that's visible clips clips
yeah yeah it's but it's a still image
yeah and just don't worry Shapira folder
mmm there were three that's awful no
it's all good yeah the images are
literally the ones that are on the
website too and that's again for
everyone that's Ori holding space.com
they are on nice yeah they're nice it's
it's what Ori does the in the yeah and
here's some cool testimonials
I'm sorry Ori
it's alright yeah that's why we got them
now we got him now I'm losing my and I'm
losing my mind I'm afraid no worries no
what when we when we when we have you
back we can also bring on other leaders
in the space and that'll be really
interesting yeah yeah do a little
roundtable on holding space and
spiritual development conscious
evolution yeah
mmm yeah yeah cool okay um do you feel
like we covered well we have to do yeah
yeah this feels good I don't think -
yeah yeah okay okay cool um let's ask
you a couple quick questions on the way
out and do you think that we come from
anywhere before birth into the earth
suits and then do you think we'd go
somewhere after death I think I'm living
in a reality that where that is likely
and maybe all perspectives can be true
okay okay um maybe that could
potentially be countered if like you
know are we you know that's the whole
thing of like is there a cow that's
currently orbiting around the Sun like
near the orbit of mercury or whatever
right am i a butterfly dreaming of being
a man yeah so I'm you know so the whole
like can everything be true thing is
like you can it yeah so uh so what you
just offered mm-hmm it feels true like
based on what I've been seeing and doing
in the past year or whatever but if you
ask me that five years ago it would have
felt completely untrue okay so the idea
is that all potential out of the
possibility space is so infinite that
there is a cow orbiting a star by
mercury somewhere it is that the I don't
know about that but it feels like it
feels like um somehow like I have
shifted into a reality that's different
like where what you offered feels like
it's true and maybe there's other people
watching this or in the world where they
think that's not true and maybe that is
not true and will continue to be not
true in there like timeline if you will
now are all possible expressions of the
simulation including the cow one
there maybe not I'm not sure and then
what's the most controversial belief you
hold mmm
that's a good one
this controversial belief I hold
probably like something related to like
magic being real and like kind of these
more out there concept that we kind of
teetered probably something like that in
general I'm not big on beliefs you know
I'm just like I had live with a lot of I
don't know yeah yeah and then do you
think we're alone in the cosmos no at
the least we're not alone if you factor
like other dimensions like inter
dimensions and stuff but what are in
those other dimensions you mean you
could call them aliens you could call
them beings you can call them energy
forms you can call them spirits and I
haven't even done that much exploring
relative to other people but it does
feel like there's something there do you
think we're in a simulation I think
we're in something interesting I think
we're in something like intelligent and
like fascinating and like mysterious so
pick your word you know yeah yeah
recently I've I really like the word God
you know you know I'm not religious but
me too yeah
I do too I really like it dude nice it
does a good job at summarizing all that
is yes yeah well God is just dog spelled
backwards I just remind you yeah yeah
this is your last question what is the
most beautiful thing in the world
something about sharing love like
sharing love with other eyeballs or like
other aware entities like there's
something there and like in our
simulation sometimes there can be really
elegant ways that that unfolds but just
that like that sense of yeah something's
something about sharing love with other
consciousnesses yeah
it's interesting how already described
it as sharing love with other
consciousnesses and other people that
have you see said love just say love mm
and you say sharing glove with of their
consciousness yeah yeah love in its
truest form is the beauty in it all you
know the most beautiful thing what you
know this in that that love like last
night I was talking it was there was a
girl they don't mean it was a few
moments in the conversation where we had
that connection of love you know that's
sincere and you you see it best but um
you know and it was nobody it was love
good stuff right then uh just kidding
but it only happened to become mean you
know few moments in the overall maybe 10
12 minute conversation or II yeah thank
you thank you thank you so nice to be on
here thank you
Wow
so nice thanks Alan thanks for
good work brother okay love you very
much likewise
thank you everyone for tuning in we
greatly appreciate it we would love to
hear your thoughts in the comments below
in the episode get talking more about
holding space with your friends your
families co-workers people online on
social media
let's get holding more space around the
world let's do this everyone whoa and
also check out the links in the bio re
holding space comm also Tori's Facebook
page check those out you shout out to
Round of August 4 producing and
directing thank you very much Ronnie and
also support the artists the
entrepreneurs the people in your
communities that are building great
things support them support simulation
if you believe in us our links are below
the patreon down there the PayPal is
down there also our link to our merch
store you can design merch you can get
paid and you can spread
thought-provoking messaging around the
world that's UB check that linked out
down there and also build the future
manifest your dreams into the world we
love you very much thank you for tuning
in and we will see you soon
Hey whoo
[Music]